roberta come salma ma quanto tempo tutto
bene cavoli peccato che devo andare a
fare la quarantasettesima dose sono un
po in ritardo se no ci prendevamo un
caffè si si io purtroppo sono ancora la
quarantasettesima perché all'inizio
avevo un po paura sai quindi ho
aspettato un attimo purtroppo sì tu
invece a che dove sei speciale a 56 chi
ma è vero che ci sono dei primi seri di
una vaccinazione d'oro tu lo sapevi
quara si arrivi alla cinquantesima dose
praticamente ai 10 per cento di sconto
sui supermercati la prima domenica del
mese e poi vuoi partecipare alla
raccolta punti praticamente ogni vaccino
sono dieci punti e il premio finale è
una ffp2 d'oro affrettati informati
perché fino al mento scorte ed ice capo
mi ha fatto piacere stimo roberto ciao
ciao buone munita di gregge ciao